good morning Hank it's to starting John
oh we're in a pecan orchards it's really
nice we're on the side of the road in
this beautiful pecan orchard tickets
question Tuesday the day that we answer
real questions from real nerdfighters
first question Hank do you have a
favorite hat hmm available at dftba.com
only for the next five days along with
all the other pizza miss gear
extra cool if you wear like oh boy I
mean that is that is a dad hat Hank
how's the tour been uh so good so good
so good it's really just - so good it's
three so Goods so so good so good so
good
Hank's right too much or not enough I
would rather have too much oh yeah of
American Jon has the book doing well
it's been number one on the New York
Times bestseller list for three straight
weeks so thank you everybody how does
one explain Pizza John to somebody who
doesn't know about pizza John I don't I
feel like it's not something you explain
it's just something you accept yeah you
just like it's the guy he wrote The
Fault in Our Stars that's all you gotta
say and then they're like oh and he's a
pizza which of you is more of a
lightweight clearly made campaign I mean
he Hank is the lightest weight John how
sad are you to be missing out on
Saturday at pod con I'm sorry to miss
the first day of pod con although
there's still gonna be plenty of live
dear Hank and John will still be there
but I'm missing it because I'm
interviewing former Vice President Joe
Biden so I'm not that sad because I'm
pretty psyched about interviewing former
Vice President Joe Biden I think people
know who Joe Biden is you don't have to
qualify them every time oh yeah yeah I
don't I don't know did I ever tell you
whole and the sidebar do you know who do
I do feel like you could say nothing and
Uncle Joe would fill up the time good
old Uncle Joe I got it what if he knows
that we call him Uncle Joe and he
introduces himself he's like hey Jon
nice to meet you I do not appreciate
being called uncle joe on vlogbrothers
they're gonna have to like prep him
paint and it's gonna be like so who's
this guy was interviewing me and they're
like well actually he made a video about
you in a pecan orchard while wearing his
own face on his torso
that was my Joe Biden dance that was
just for Joe no one else gets to enjoy
it Hank our hotdogs sandwiches no
opinion
so a thing that Hank and I have been
doing on tour is we have decided that we
have too many opinions so every day Hank
and I are abandoning one opinion I've
abandoned my opinion on whether a hot
dog is a sandwich I've abandoned my
opinion on Phil Collins's music I no
longer have an opinion about it I've
abandoned my opinion on other people's
opinions of M&M flavors yeah which is a
big deal for Hank because it was
difficult hardcore anti peanut butter
M&M so bad nope but oh you got to love
them there you go
I'm gonna abandon one opinion every day
until I find that I am left with some
really core important opinions
hey Hank how would you summarize the
book tour experience in the form of a
haiku you didn't give any prep for this
you didn't give any prep for this now
that's you naughty you're not even close
nauseated bus bound drunk again hanging
out with John a lot birds fly around me
I don't know if you knew that about the
tour experience the nauseated bus
hey Hank where can I get pizza miss Gere
and for how much longer somebody knows
how to get on question Tuesday
this way no you have to go to dftba.com
and it's only available until Friday
happy pizza miss everybody Hank I will
see you whenever you get back oh there
you are
Oh psh someone else can we get a
discount code for pizza miss merch and I
decided you know what yeah for the next
24 hours if you use the discount code
pizza you will get one percent one
percent off of your purchase at
dftba.com it's a great discount Hank or
anything on the whole site hooked up for
anything on the whole site one percent